Though it made her career, Megan Fox's experiences
filming the first two "Transformers" movies had
huge consequences on her professional life and
her relationship with director Michael Bay.
There's no doubt that Megan Fox is a
talented and beautiful actress. She
was declared the sexiest woman in the world in a
2008 online poll and seemed to be on top of the
world after she scored the role of Mikaela
Banes in Paramount's "Transformers." Fox,
and her co-star Shia LaBeouf, received
major attention for their roles,
but there was a moment when the actor's
career took a turn for the worse.
Hollywood is a fast-paced and ruthless
place, which means that if an actor or
actress makes a comment they shouldn't have
or a personal move they might regret, it will,
unfortunately, stain their career in some
way or another. For Fox, it all started when
she said something that might have gotten her
"canceled" had it happened a few years later,
in the so-called "cancel culture" era.
Of course, everyone makes mistakes,
and Fox knows that today, but the
toll it took on her is undeniable
Fox's career didn't start with the "Transformers"
franchise, but it definitely boosted her stardom.
It seemed like she was on her way to becoming
an A-lister, until 2009, when she sat down with
Wonderland Magazine and talked about her time
on set with "Transformers" director Michael
Bay. When she was asked what it was like to
work with the "Blockbuster King," she said,
"He's like Napoleon and he
wants to create this insane,
infamous madman reputation. He wants to
be like Hitler on his sets, and he is."
Following her comments, Fox was booted
from the "Transformers" franchise,
with her character being written out of 2011's
"Transformers: Dark of the Moon." Fox's fallout
from the billion-dollar series was controversial,
leading to a turbulent case of "he said she said."
Following the news, Fox's PR team came out
swinging, saying that the actress wasn't fired
from the role, with the decision to quit being all
her own. Shortly after, Michael Bay told GQ that
executive producer Steven Spielberg compelled
him to fire Fox for her comments. Shia LaBeouf
added that Fox was let go because she started,
quote, "s--t-talking" the film's "captain."
Ultimately, Fox and Bay's spat was
short-lived, as they ended up working
together in the live-action reboot of "Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles," which Bay produced.
Fox never took a break or "quit" acting —
she maintained a constant flow of roles,
but it seemed like her career wasn't the same
after her time on "Transformers" was wrapped up.
It's not a secret that some movie stars
often get typecast into one type of genre.
This is unfortunate, of course, and
in the late 2000s, Fox was feeling it.
"It's weird, I just wouldn't peg
you for mechanical. Oh my god."
"Oh, you know, I don't really broadcast it."
In a 2009 interview with Jimmy Kimmel, she
explained how she felt sexualized from the
beginning of her career, particularly
in her brief moment in "Bad Boys II."
Fox also starred in Diablo Cody-penned horror
movie "Jennifer's Body," which gained backlash
due to the sexism that surrounded it. Since then,
the project has become a horror cult classic.
There's no hidden truth behind Fox being cast
as the "hot girl." In an interview with ET,
Cody and Fox reunited and chatted about the
film. Fox revealed that the pressure of being
objectified and oversexualized took a toll on her,
which stemmed from her role in "Transformers."
Since her iteration of the "Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles" franchise wrapped up in 2016,
Fox hasn't worked with Bay. Her most notable
role since then has been her stint on "New Girl."
Of course, there's always more to
every story, but her comments about
Michael Bay's directing techniques and
major typecasting are just a couple of
reasons why Fox was never the same after
her role in the "Transformers" franchise.